hi everyone my name is Anne wima my Ruby
global shaper I'm a lawyer by profession
and my my question today or the question
I seek to address is what I want to see
so that we can end internal and external
conflicts which are taking lives and
resources in Africa I think the biggest
challenge to leaders right now is to
engage in our consultative and
collaborative approach reach out to
other leaders in those countries where
they where conflict has been striving
for long to think about the people that
they are serving to put the people's
interests before their own it's time to
break the cycle stop look back and think
what can I do my people are dying might
will have never known peace how can I
make change how can I make this positive
and the best way to do it is collaborate
reach out to other partners i'm sure all
other leaders are willing to help you to
achieve your home